let's go to you let's go to mark from
Newport we haven't heard from mark from
Newport for a while what's going on mark
hi David thank you for taking my call I
wanted to know your opinion I'm sure
you've seen I know recently there's the
Pew Research study that showed the
decline of religiosity in the u.s. yes
and I personally am worried about some
of the resulting societal consequences
hmm but I wanted to know your thoughts
well we did have to tell me what
consequences you're worried about I
guess a couple things so according to
Pew the same group that provided the
first seven wonders is they said for
example religious people are overall
happier there overall have better health
outcomes
there was an Ohio State University study
that said controlling for social
economic status and race and income and
age that religious people live longer
University of Indiana said religious
folks give more to charity
which is true again controlling for all
of those factors excuse me a Harvard
Medical School said that religious
people suffer significantly less mental
health problems so I guess to be clear I
am NOT saying that the only way we can
improve those categories is religion I'm
saying that the decline in religion is
pulling the rug out from so much and I
don't think we'll be able to pick up the
pieces as fast as they're falling if I
praise that okay why do you think that
the states that have a lower percentage
of folks that are religious seem to be
better off economically in terms of
Education in terms of health outcomes in
terms of mental health why do you think
that is well I think looking between
states is actually not controlling for
enough variables like you're not
accounting for like the state level
government so what I what I think
controls like best isolates the variable
of religiosity is looking within
specific states where yours they're
holding constant you know governance
history that sort of thing interesting a
specific state
which which holds more variables
constant in every metric I just gave
religious people turn out better yeah
I've just not seen that data everything
I'm looking at has it has that minimum
failed to demonstrate that it is because
of religion that some of these
differences exist but I've I've not even
seen the data you're citing so I would
have to look into it but you know a big
big picture I'm not worried about and I
you know when we look at countries that
are less religious as well you know that
you you could make the same argument
which is well the countries that are
less religious might for other reasons
be doing be have happier people so to
speak or whatever the case may be but
I've just not seen the data that you're
citing so I'd like to look at it sure
like look III think what you just said
is very interesting to look so for
example of like like I think the obvious
example is Western Europe where
religiosity is far lower than Eastern
Europe and Western Europe is much
happier but then you know I don't think
comparing like England for example to a
you know former member of the Soviet
bloc is a great comparison but looking
in a lot of these countries like for
example this is like what the Pugh debt
the Pugh data demonstrates when they
look at religious folks within specific
countries they're holding variables
constant that within any or most
countries religious folks are happier
yeah that was not my takeaway from the
Pew study but it has been a little while
since I looked at it so I'll review the
data mark but a very interesting
question that you're bringing up yeah
this is I think the fifth time you
accepted my call so thank you so much I
really appreciate it all right mark very
good to hear from you thank you so much
and I'm sure we will be hearing from him
again let's go next to our caller from
the nine seven three area code who's
calling today from 973 Dave let me yes
it is hi so I was just kind of curious
why you don't hear a lot of left-wing
positions being argued from our
right-wing perspective and my example
knows would be something like climate
change where we typically focus on
things like the science and stuff that
and gets put up for debate in the
intermedia but you never hear something
like a lot of our national enemies like
Russia Iran or Venezuela their economies
are very heavily dependent on
hydrocarbons so the best way to attack
them would be to take out their
economies so you never hear things like
that I'm just kind of wondering why
there's actually a big debate about this
about whether it makes sense to argue
for our policy based on arguments that
would be appealing to the other side and
it's it's not clear to me that it's a
good idea I've read really good
arguments on both sides one being yes we
should even if there are arguments in
favor of a policy we want that don't
match up with our priorities if it's
going to influence someone else we
should still make those arguments but
then there are lots of other folks like
for example Nathan J Robinson who I
interviewed who said he said he thinks
it's a bad idea that he should be
arguing for the policies we believe are
the right ones for the reasons we
believe that they are the right one so I
think first we have to when you're
asking why don't we hear it more first
we have to figure out whether it's a
good idea and it seems to be an open
question at this point at least on many
issues okay good yeah I'll do my
homework Bob I'm go ahead so those who
in wondering what the impact of weather
might be on the upcoming Democratic
primary with the El Nino coming up for
2020 whether or not more inclement
colder weather could potentially impact
candidates who have less voter
enthusiasm so some like Joe Biden let
you hurt more than someone like Bernie
well that it's certainly conceivable but
I would we can't control that and either
way if that's going to be a factor it's
going to be a factor I don't think it's
one of it's fine to speculate but I
don't think it's very actionable one way
or the other okay great thank you very
much all right appreciate the phone call
thank you